hey guys it's the 15th of December my
name is Justin this is the second to
last news we're making in Australia this
year so let's make the most of it xbox
one speeds Nintendo switch specs and a
mario game I can't play we've got it all
here's what's happening Super Mario run
is out now for everybody everybody that
has an iOS device that is don't you HTC
whatever I don't to play the game anyway
Super Mario run is free to download but
if you want to play past the first three
levels you'll need to pay 10 bucks to
unlock everything the game is an auto
runner in which you control Mario with
one hand as he runs through environments
full of obstacles and enemies research
firm super data has reported they expect
the mobile game to reach around 13
million downloads and rake in 60 million
bucks in its first month for those
playing at home that's a lot less than
Pokemon go but Pokemon go arrived on iOS
and Android simultaneously why won't you
take my money in Nintendo I don't
understand the publisher have said an
android version is coming but they
haven't said when I'm guessing it'll be
when all our apple fanatic friends have
stopped playing it next up Microsoft has
released a new update for xbox one which
makes downloading games away faster the
update notes indicate you'll get up to
eighty percent faster speeds for Xbox
one downloads if your home broadband
speed is above 100 megabits if you're
under that threshold you'll apparently
still experience quote more consistent
performance that is up to forty percent
faster than before Microsoft added that
additional optimizations have also made
background downloads more resilient to
intermittent connectivity issues and the
update also adds stability and
performance improvements finally
ventureBeat is reporting some clues
about what we can expect performance
wise from the nintendo switch to sources
suggested that the switch will use
invidious maxwell graphics processing
technology not the company's nua pascal
architecture it was confirmed during the
switch announcement event that the
console would be using a variant of
nvidia's tegra chip that would suggest
the console will have more than one
teraflop of performance markedly less
than the six teraflops of xboxes project
scorpio over 1.8 teraflops of the
standard ps4 VentureBeat report
custom Maxwell tegra in the machine is
still powerful enough to play Nintendo
style games rely on quality art /
horsepower but don't expect switch
software to match the graphical fidelity
of the highest and PS war games this
isn't necessarily a bad thing though at
least not according to market
researchers like Jon Peddie who says too
many pundits and fanboys and investors
make a serious mistake when they tried
to compare and contrast Nintendo with
Sony and Microsoft em ponto has the
nation the affordable accessible product
and performance is never a leading
criteria for them it is gameplay and
immersion there never a technology
pioneer let me know down in that comment
section if you're keen for the switch
and remember to pop by gamespot next
tuesday where we're counting down our
top games of the year in a live stream
will also have the top five stories for
you tomorrow so pop by again then